Welcome everyone to a brand new show get excited for a brand new show smash your hardest bro fist for brand new show!
introducing
Cringe tuesdays
Cringe Tuesday's everybody. Let me know if you're excited brand new show. Let's 👏  just 👏 jump 👏  into it
It's the same concept as any other video
yEa BuT yOuR hAiR cUt Is MaKiNg Me CrInGe
ShuT tehh fehck up
Cringe Tuesdays, sound check Madison Brookes recording. I'm not getting any sound. (smooch)
smooch
what the fu-? what the hell.. ew!
Did he just lick my ear?
It works, try it
ew
Yeah
Going live... sound check.. sound check good. Now that I'm starting to do live stream
This is a perfect example for me to learn what not to do. There's good lord knows I need the training [oof]
Therefore we can watch these news anchors fails Cringe Tuesdays, Cringe Tuesdays. Let's go
[ laughing in meatballs ]
The classic
Why is there not blood on that? This is so obviously fake. Okay, don't make me laugh. I want the pure cringe
Come on, when people saying dumb SH
So the Dalai Lama
Walks into a pizza shop. Oh my god i've seen this..
Pizza yeah, pizza pizza shop and says, can you make me one with everything?
What's that? I'm sorry
He doesn't speak English, why would he understand your joke Jesus Christ? What's the point so dumb
You know what? I mean?
Do you know what I mean?
Can you make me one with everything?
No offense I'm sure it's a great guy but this is kind of person that in real life
In real life no one
These people I make these awful jokes and you're just for the sake of politeness you laugh along you go, haha
That's that's funny one with everything and you go about your day, but in reality no, no one likes your joke. I'll all have that
Disconnect now thanks to the Internet. It just becomes pure cringe so many things that previously
HEuh were just Haeh
God God, uh
Troubling snow in dealing with the bitter cold. Are you dreaming of fishing or boating? Ah, yes
That sounds at least the boating part sounds good. You can get a taste of summer this weekend at the State Fairgrounds
Oh god you know she's gonna destroy herself
And definitely the place to be thinking about summer
Especially if you're the outdoorsy type, I'm Stephanie so VR and coming up
We'll show you some things you can do,(come on cringe tuesdays) to have fun in the warm weather
*Ric Flair Woo*
AhhhHHHHAhhhHHh
This is what I've been saying all along
Women can't drive. That's right
Why do I make this ironic takes, you know?
someone's gonna make a compilation out of it eventually and be like look well if you do this
Shhtteh feHKkahp
Wahmen can't drive bicycle
I've said it before,
I said it many times
Weman bicycle
Women not
By sickle
Women bicycle. What is this video?
Bah bah bah dah, dah
You can't argue with the fax and logix those little guys are cute and cuddly looking and the Beavers
I've seen are bigger and not yeah, and they don't look as friendly so I don't know
Maybe I've seen my beavers in the wrong place
That's funny come on I want some cringe man, it's cringe Tuesday's god dammit just show me
Cringe Tuesday's, please
Cringe, I just wanna cringe is that too much to Fripp an ass, dude
Suppose every demand for nail on squawking. He did seal comfort welcomed a language
Oh my god, he's using the metal to save her
Haha ramen fools income he just goes. Oh, let me save her with my giant metal. Here you go
Greenish Tuesday's green Tuesday girls were completely engrossed by it when we were watching it
It really does make you feel like you're inside this eleven year old girl
God damn it, the people not hear themselves speak. I love that when someone says something completely
innocently but the person listening and goes like oh god, why did my brain go there in a
Profoundly, wholesome way
It's according to Oxfam of the world's 85 richest people is equal to the three and a half billion
Poorest people. It's fantastic
And this is a great winning because it inspires
Everybody gets the motivation to look up to the 1% and say I want to become one of those people
I'm gonna fight hard to get up to the top. This is fantastic news. And of course, I applaud it
85 people have all the will
Need someone to look up to
Know is it better for me to double-fist it or should I do one utter at a time? I am being a beginner
Keep that in mind
I apologize to every goat farmer out there that thinks and every ex-boyfriend. I
Want the cringe man, I'm just laughing. This is not try not to laugh. Give me some
Okay, oh no hoo-ha let him hear himself get caught
God Texas senator Ted Cruz Oh
Ah
Go just go Oh God
Florida Senator Marco Rubio, whoever might not see this. Oh
My god, it's something totally like, don't worry about it. I'll call your name
Former Florida Governor Jeb Bush
And there they are then there with two oh
My god, that is amazing Hey look at him look at this guy, what are you doing? Idiot? Haha. I
Don't know anything about this man
I don't know anything about his politics, but at least he seems like an honest person if we're not going
It seems like he would follow roots at the very least. I mean, that's that's a good quality, right? All right, Sally
Thank you and to find which sunscreen is best for your skin five ways to keep your family safe from the Sun
Check out the top leg on the pittsburgh channel. It's on the left-hand side of the homepage. I want whatever you're using
It's the best reply I've ever heard yeah
That's great. Ten out of ten responds. Yeah
Great, Tuesday
Greg dared a
Wendy Williams under the influence on her live TV show now
I haven't watched this and I don't like Wendy Williams so immediately I know I'm gonna like this
But at the second say on another point of view, yeah
I thought about how soul-crushing it must be to do those daily shows
what it's all about so happy and like
I would fucking get smashed too. If I had to do that what she had to do. So we'll watch days
Blac Chyna
Is suing Kardashian's forgetting her show can't she's blaming them because allegedly there were emails alleging that Khloe
Highly we emails alleged
Relationship
Good deliberate just wants publicity jr. Thing
And even promised the Kardashians would film extra episodes to make up for the cancellation of the time and black show
I will do what you want
Khloe
allegedly
Said that she was concerned for their brands. I can't watch this is awful
cringe to say everyone smash like
Subscribe, have you not subscribed yet? Subscribe
For Tim's new date or else there will be consequences. I am apparently Wendy Williams. I can't speak
Thank you guys for watching another video. See you tomorrow. And as always have a wholesome life and I see you never hi
Tuber simulator it's now so relevant that it's got a brand new minigame
craniac
drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine like game and you say there's more of course there is
New knowledge perks new quests and new pics links and legs guys
legs 😳😳😳